[Music]
hello everyone I'm Peter also notice now
though I am part of the iron Lords
podcast and we were asked to review
project winter by other ocean
interactive it is a survival game
against your other survivors if you will
you can play as either a survivor or a
traitor in this frozen wilderness you
get you have to go through the game and
get your wood and get your food and keep
warm make supplies and craft them in the
team cabin if you are one of the traders
you can be voted out so I was able to
play as both the trader and also as a
survivor the survivor you have to work
with your teammates
collectively everything done you have to
unlike unlock certain areas by each
click by two or three people four people
openly on levers they unlock doors you
go in there you get your supplies once
you end up doing that you can eventually
call upon your your plane to come pick
you up and then once you get picked up
you get to leave and you know game over
you win now as the traitor you were
there to prevent your survivors from
leaving the area and to do that you can
kill them in many ways bear traps guns
mines and you get drops put randomly
throughout the whole entire game if
these survivors don't complete missions
that are given to them and when you
place a survivor there's already caches
on the ground and you can go over to
them and you can grab them and you can
end up opening them up and they're full
supplies already so you have the ability
to easily get a handful of different
things that you're looking for now as
for the graphics of this game
they're very clean the angles are great
like to call them clean boxy the the
polygon looks on on the characters are I
love them call me old-fashioned call me
what you want but the the way that they
have them shaded your character it looks
like you're one of them you know it's
its own entity and the creatures that
are running around is great there the
gameplay is also it's fun you need more
of a tutorial because I was walking
around one game probably for good my
first game for about 10 minutes going
what am i doing what do I have to do
what I have to get go through with this
the gaming series somewhere town of
Salem which I've played for before and
it's a lot of fun it's web-based
browser-based it's all chat there's no
voice chat where this is voice chat
every chat I got into for every match I
got into people were just talking smack
telling everyone that they're a liar
tell everyone that they're cheaters
saying your trailer traitor traitor
don't believe him he's garbage I mean
talking down to people it was it was
really discouraging to wanted to
continue to play that was the only thing
that I really disliked about about the
game was actually the voice shot now
when you're walking through the area you
actually have a distance to your other
players so if you're too far you can't
hear them talking which was good and I
found myself walking away from people
going I don't even want to hear their
crap because they're just really being
rude now even should be a lot to learn
or fire the gun like you got to turn a
certain way click the mouse and then
shoot almost like you you had to point
your cursor in the direction you know to
go
the
game has some replayability when you're
with a bunch of friends I can see myself
talking to help my buddy isn't going hey
what are you doing tonight let's let's
let's let's pick this game up well it's
you know when it's on sale and you know
be able to do that get have a couple of
beers hang out for twenty bucks though
it seems a little steep because it's
perfect for with friends so if you're
gonna charge us 20 bucks give us a
couple of copies give us a two three
copies I mean I know that seems like
it's a lot but at the same time you get
a couple of friends playing with you you
have fun playing also so they also have
an in-game store they have some cool
masks and antlers and some next like
scarfs and things like that
I guess the they wanted to see about
getting a little more funds but that
stuff's expensive too five bucks three
bucks I was like what and I understand
you're trying to you know get some
microtransaction deal in here but so
alright so I would like to say thank you
all for for some byte and listening to
this iron Lords podcast first look Acts
project winter by other ocean
interactive and you know like I said if
you're gonna if you got a couple of
buddies he's gonna hang out do it pick
it up play it fun good you know you know
what happens you get a couple of buddies
in a room together they're you know
playing some old games like Goldeneye or
or you know Halo you're just gonna be
talking smack and having fun and this is
this is where that game is and it's good
so thanks again and Sundays what o'clock
is our lowest podcast please stop by
take a look and listen to the fantastic
show we are we are going to
at our 100th episode right around the
corner so thank you all have a fantastic
day
[Music]